all right today's topic basically this
is trending on Twitter but a user by the
name of King Kasich wrote Harry lennix
and Tiana Taylor's ability to have
dangerously high appeal while
simultaneously looking like rock
wheelers will always amaze me and then
basically Twitter was ablaze by that
comment how people hate black people so
much how how black people can sit up
here and say that's not my problem or or
she does look like a Rottweiler that's
fine that's fine but in an and you want
to talk about how old people are so
sense that if they want us to cancel
freedom of speech why is this your
speech why are you so comfortable
tearing down black women women and no
other race look around look under look
around when are Hispanic women ever
compared to dogs
when do they do that when do they do
that to white women I know we know a lot
of our viewers are not from the black
community so you guys may be confused as
to what's going on but to just keep it
brief you just have to understand that
like for black people self-image is like
a huge problem in a very different way
than for other communities yeah and
especially between both genders was in
the black community there's oftentimes a
lot of problems in that regard but this
is where that's coming from basically
people feel like black men throw women
under the bus a lot or trash him and so
preach I'll let you go first if I look
at the comment that was said it was very
uncalled for I say like why would you
say that but it's Twitter people will
say what they gotta say I understand and
I sympathize with her when she said like
yeah you said goes against freedom of
speech but why do you choose that as
your speech I understand and I get a
sympathize with that when she said
something about its banning people do
that we don't hear Latinos do that I do
like just in the comedy environment
example of Sarah Jessica Parker people
being calling an hour horse I really
understand why she loved what she look
whatever but not to me that I'm called
for as well I gotta admit yet there is
some place where take the do take the
liberty to to bash black woman like that
but why is it that important why do you
put so much emphasis on
that person that doesn't matter is just
a troll and that's what a troll do why
do you put so much emphasis and I know
it hurt this is a lot of thing that's
gonna be powerful it's gonna be thrown
at you same thing as a lot of things
that I heard Florida is throwing at us
it's not the same thing though why is it
not the same thing because the amount of
negative comments levy that black women
for their looks is disproportionately
high that's correct
you can say you're in the public eye you
should be able to handle it better
that's not what I'm trying to say I'm
just saying you're in the public eye it
is gonna be a lot of thrown at you but
it's not that it's like when you hear it
so often and you're and you know
especially as a woman you're really
taught that a lot of your value lies in
your looks but then as a black woman
your looks are set even further back
true so then you see a black man who you
continuously try to defend in all
circumstances and then you see some
random person it's like the tip of the
iceberg but you've had a whole history
in a whole lifetime of people and the
world continuously telling you that
you're on the track so why does it
happen so much there someone asked me
like do I think black men throw black
women under the bus pretty consistent if
anything I don't think we have as much
solidarity towards black women as they
have towards us people should be allowed
to say what they want to say was the
freedom of speech yeah but like what she
says like why do you feel compelled to
say that I never understood why anybody
wants to get on the internet and be like
this person looks like a dog this person
looks like an eggplant this person like
to me I never quite understood if you
want to say it's okay like I'm not to me
it's not something I would do why I
would ever encourage there's no easy
solution to this kind of thing I think
the only thing we can do is just be
patient with time and understand that
these things are improving whether it is
black women women winning all these
Beauty awards and beauty pageants and
that standards of beauty are changing
and that you know more of us are being
represented in all these different media
platforms change takes time you know
you're talking about hundreds of years
of colonization and and negative
marketing being placed in the minds of
our youth and that being passed through
us generationally in terms of what we
used to think beauty standards were
we're taking a long time to undo that
the fact I like yo had natural hair is a
new movement that's really been picking
up fact that a lot of these things are
changing it's a time taking process but
I do think things are improving I even
see a lot of more black men trying to be
more conscious of the of their bias I
mean I had that bite
when I was really young not as much as a
lot of my friends in high school but I
definitely saw a little bit of in myself
and it's hard by bias towards whiteness
yeah where I think big Geordie of us
have it because of what we are in this
world but people don't know they have it
no they don't know it and they don't
know how it manifests is I have friends
who say stuff like this I'm like I would
never date a black cuz white women are
just better he's like now there's
nothing wrong with that
Wow you don't see how you've
internalized racism that you think one
race is superior to the other right so
it's so engrained in some people that
they aren't even recognized and if they
are a part of an issue right or that
they're perpetuating and that's why was
my first wrestle all these moons of
people being proud of like yeah yo she
wants you want you want they want look
at this look at this I don't care but
it's not for you it's not so much that
it's not for me it's not tough hold on I
don't well yes I'm part of but it's not
for you would mean it's not for me
explain cuz it's black woman winning
this yes right and so what you as a
black person you can kind of feel some
sense of pride but they're the ones who
are really touched by this why because
they're seeing themselves finally being
desired black men have always kind of
been desirable creatures so it's not for
you yeah you did what I'm saying like
that is their thing I understand why
they would be ecstatic about but I think
it was either yeah but I am happy that
they're feeling good about it that's why
I asked myself the question why did I
give it then you analyze stuff and you
go back there like no it is important I
didn't think it was important I didn't
think it was important I thought it was
the same thing as the black first black
woman to be a Bachelorette I was like ah
but even that at first I was like uh who
cares the first black Teletubby I'm like
but there's something behind that this
if we want to be representative even in
the trash spots yeah even in the service
the Teletubbies give us a telephone it's
just like baseball player the first
black baseball player you don't Robinson
mm-hmm it's great yeah I don't set that
we said I'm gonna be really happy when
we're gonna have trash baseball player
than I am
be black in the league that means a trap
this the same standard at everybody else
it was not just the first player he was
great at what he did he had to be great
just to be like inside you know I mean
so basically his skill outperformed the
race yes right there businessman so they
wanted great talent that's like my mom
she wants me to marry an Ethiopian girl
but I remember one time I was dating
this white girl one time and she's like
never but she found out she was a doctor
she's like Oh take her I want her
married because she was more happy that
I had a doctor girl then I had a what
you know say so
her her ambitions outperformed her ease
that was one of the funniest moments of
my life and I dub the doctor like a week
later - you don't think they soon as my
mind was for it I was like like mom
you'll get to be happy before I am and
so you know I hear your frustrations and
I mean listen well on this channel
especially we try to never preach
anything that negatively reflects the
image or at least physically of
blackwood we may criticize a woman who
happens to be black but never on the
basis of her skin tone I would never
think of doing that because it's not in
me
does that make sense like even behind
closed doors I never make those comments
because I don't feel that way mmhmm yeah
I mean yeah cuz I also grew up in
Ethiopia so for me the idea of like
beauty and blackness is always like
ingrained in me as a young age oh it's
not black when we're super attractive
but I recognize that for a lot people
will grow up in the West or a lot of
people who grow up in places where
colorism is super relevant their
propensity towards light-skinned to
thinking that dark skin is because it's
like self-loathing it's ingrained in you
you've been taught that your dark skin
is terrible so if you see it reflected
elsewhere then you start to react to it
negatively get away from you start to be
more aggressive more dismissive you
start to guess like more because you
just want to get away from that because
that's reflecting yourself and your own
problems towards yourself you did what
I'm saying to you and the worst ones are
the ones that know ya still do it yeah
it's like when people have these biases
where they're like black women are
difficult and so what happens that these
black men become more defensive and so
they encourage more defensive behavior
because they're being more defensive
that was funny because it was a wide new
dance in that to me yeah black women are
are difficult to approach I was like
rather awkwardness it's not her hate see
you it's just certain job
you send yourself like dude man that's
awkward to anybody yeah even dudes look
at you like look give this that's my
black woman is you yeah you know that
feeling when you see a black person and
the way they talk about round white was
different like coach was you I'm talking
about the groveling or you make yourself
smaller to allow them to have the space
yeah absolutely
my mom when we immigrated here she
really felt that need to like yeah if
we're like if I'm in a black spot in a
black bar we talking loud we while out
not as much as we're doing in a white
bar just because of the image that is
just doing its comedy thing and being on
TV you know there is a difference
between being a white person in comedy
or on TV or in the media and a black
person because what white person messes
up he messes up if I mess up we mess up
the look of the whole community messes
up you know I mean so yeah that's a bit
why for the same reason that we tend to
not think enough space were already
noticeable and stuff like that so leach
estrada yeah yeah we have the right to
roast anybody and roast whoever you want
I'm never gonna tell you not to do
whatever you want I would just say
understand that when you criticize black
women on just solely on the base of
their looks understand it's low-hanging
fruit I think I would never think of
describing another black person as a big
lift
why no monkey looking like you can but
do you not understand where that comes
from and where those kind of words and
language come from do you not realize
what you're reusing but just think about
why you're saying it where it comes from
am i internalizing vocabulary that is
really from a place cuz if I am then
maybe I need to unlearn that's all we
wanna know what you guys think leave
your comments below what do you guys
think about the comment or her reaction
[Music]